Let me tell you about a man called Victor
Gruen.
Born in Austria, he moved to the United States
just before the Second World War broke out
and became an architect.
And he looked at the suburban sprawl that
was taking over America
all the people just commuting back and forth,
back and forth
between home and work in their cars, and thought
that what they needed
was something like the old city centres and
downtowns that he knew.
What he needed was a city centre for the suburban
sprawl
and what he came up with was the idea for
the shopping mall.
'Course, he had some more utopian vision for
it.
He thought, oh, this is going to be wonderful,
there's going to be homes, and shops, and
schools, and even hospitals,
all working together and being this new space.
Unfortunately, money and politics got in the
way of his utopian visions
and what you ended up with, twenty years later
when the idea crossed the Atlantic,
was this: Brent Cross Shopping Centre,
described by a friend of mine as "Hell on
Earth on a Saturday".
It's the reason I've been driving around looking
for a parking space for about half an hour.
Now, Victor Gruen did not want this.
He did not want these temples to consumerism
with every psychological trick in the book
designed to get you to buy.
One of those psychological tricks got named
after him:
the Gruen Transfer, the idea that there are
a few seconds after you walk in
with all this new stimulus, where your brain
just gets a little bit confused
and almost hypnotises you into buying more.
Doesn't matter whether it's true -- it's probably
not, the evidence is shaky,
but what matters: it was named after him.
And at that point, he was railing against
what he called
these "bastard" offspring of his original
idea.
Well, this is what we've ended up with.
He died in 1980, at a point where there was
a new shopping mall
opening in the United States roughly every
week or so.
Which was not what he wanted...
...but things have changed.
Economic downturns and the rise of the internet
mean that now a lot of those old malls are
closing down.
And the new spaces that are popping up in
their path?
They're a lot more like his original designs.
They're pedestrianised high streets, and they're
big, open spaces
with actual space to sit down that isn't just
convincing you to buy.
From beyond the grave, Victor Gruen might
have the last laugh.
Not that that helps me, when that guy just
took the last parking space.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name
here!]